during an interview with ign the
director of godzilla vs cong adam
wingard
had this to say to a question thrown in
by fans a question whether godzilla will
have
new powers or not in the upcoming flick
again you know i don't want to spoil the
movie but i will say that you're going
to see godzilla do things
you've never seen him do before the fun
thing about when godzilla's causing
problems is that
that means he's blowing a lot of [ __ ] up
and he's causing a lot of destruction in
mayhem
and so are we going to see godzilla
reveal new powers in this upcoming
showdown with
the king of skull island of course we
have seen him with the atomic breath and
a nuclear pulse
and even in his burning form but what
other powers does he have
and can we make an educated guess as to
which ones he will take from all the
movies
or from new imaginations to put it here
in the monster verse
so let's get down to it we have done an
earlier video of
the 20 powers of godzilla you would be
surprised at the types of powers that
godzilla has had over the years
from the staple and lovable atomic
breath to actually possessing extreme
unimaginable powers and even funny ones
while most of them are awesome and
deadly quite a couple of the powers that
he had in the past
were actually funny but which one of
these would he show off in godzilla vs
kong
of course he has had the atomic breath
godzilla has always used this version of
the deadly range attack which
is when he generates and manipulates
radiation within his body
in a way that allows the g-man to shape
the beam by exhaling it through his
mouth
godzilla has also used a very powerful
shock wave of nuclear energy from his
entire body which is useful when he is
restrained or in close combat
the nuclear pulse that was only possible
with mothra's help
of course we will not see a repeat of
the flying godzilla or the superkick or
the magnetic powers
he has had in the past these are better
left back in the past and forgotten
what we might see is something akin to
shin godzilla's thermal belt flame
in 2016 shin retains the trademark
atomic breath but his
godzilla signature weapon initially
takes place
takes form of a cloud of smoke exhaled
from his mouth and then a stream of fire
called the super thermal radiation
particle belt flame
which is capable of burning through
entire city blocks at high speed
and as we have seen in one of the tv
spots of godzilla firing his atomic
breath at the ground
it could be something like shin spaw but
in a unique way
as we can also see the shock wave and
gushing winds spread out
the radiate from that area another
possible power that godzilla might be
seen having in this march movie
is the spiral heat ray well maybe that's
what we actually want to see
and not the producers but as we have
seen in the trailer clips and tv spots
godzilla was shooting his atomic breath
quite a lot virtually every at
everything in 2014 he used it twice
in king of the monsters like four times
or so but here
he has already broken the record just in
the trailers and tv spots
which might become normalized for
viewers until he releases an even
powerful version like
the spiral heat ray on maybe kong or
possibly mechagodzilla in the end game
battle
this is a unique power that as it
possesses another set of beams that
spiral alongside the main beam
which gives it extra power enough to
even vaporize skies and ghidorah
in the movie godzilla final wars but
then again
maybe not we might not see these powers
in the big screen
but again adam wingard did say we would
see godzilla do
things that we have never seen him do
before so that means
even though there may be no new super
breath or
no nuclear pulse in the movie godzilla
would utilize his current powers to the
maximum extent
and become creative with them one of
these was when godzilla is shown to
destroy the aircraft carrier from
underwater and second when you he shut
it at the ground
creating a massive nuclear bomb like
shock wave that radiate out in all
directions there was also the tail scene
where he uses it to destroy
two navy warships and his dorsal plate
while
cutting another warship in half like a
christmas cake
one thing is for sure though we will be
seeing the king of the monsters duking
out with kong
and therefore he would have to up his
game and
the [ __ ] slap is just one move in a big
bag of kaiju surprises
we would definitely see him using the
surroundings and his intellect to be
able to catch kong and beat him up
the battle is said to be brutal and very
animalistic so there would be kicks and
punches and slaps and bites and tail
swipes like we have
never seen before and oh yeah one more
thing we are going to see
the king of the mosses in a different
light like literally godzilla had been
glowing extra blue
and pulsating more with nuclear energy
than in his earlier movies
after all toho is taking the rights back
to godzilla after this movie
and therefore godzilla will be seen in
his ultimate master vs form
one that is nuclear energy incarnated
and so with that we come to the end of
the video leave your thoughts down there
in the comment section
also do leave a thumbs up for support
and also subscribe if you haven't
so that you'll be a part of the mind cue
family and slap that bell button for
regular updates on godzilla vs kong news
monster content and a lot more right
here on mind cue
take care fam